Neal was 9 years old when he auditioned
he is one of 2,000 kids he had never
auditioned before I was in class and the
teacher heard about the role and said
I'd be very good for it and I never
really thought about acting before but I
auditioned he had a quality that was
reminiscent of the character from the
animated film that time I met Neal I was
10 he seemed really cool they really
liked me so we flew to LA and started
show me two weeks later the jungle isn't
a long as safe I returned him to where
he belongs I knew that we'd be working
together for a long time between voice
recordings and rehearsals and motion
capture it wasn't that hard because
there were a lot of people there and a
lot of puppets that's what I interacted
with and I got used to it if you send it
back to the man village they'll ruin
them they'll make a man out of him Neal
is this rock kid quick study we used
that whole period of motion capture
almost as rehearsal and then finally
several months later when he was gonna
be under the lights and in costume and
in makeup he became a very facile actor
you will always be my son there's just
one scene in the trailer
the Tigers jumping out at me and I have
to be scared
and I wasn't getting the right reaction
so John actually got behind me and I
didn't know this and I looked and I saw
him and he screamed them the top of his
lung and I got so scared and they used
that in the film and so funny
you